[Music]
life is pretty much
out of
everybody's control
we make plans in life and
god probably looks at you like yeah okay
you know he already has everything set
for you
when you go through tough times you have
to know that you know you're getting put
in these positions for a reason we may
not know those reasons but that's how i
look at a lot of things that go on in my
life and i think it kind of makes it
easier even though i think about it all
the time
i think it kind of weighs less on my
shoulders when i say you know i'm gonna
just pray about it and
whatever god has planned that's that's
what's going to happen
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it took all of us for by surprise
because i was already in the in the
midst of trying to look for a team
overseas you know what country i was
gonna wanted to go to and
i signed with the agency
and i started you know giving her all
these information on film and
she calls me and we're just trying to
you know figure out what's going on and
she's like um i was doing some research
and
fiba has a rule about you know headgear
or gear that you can wear in the games
and um we didn't know the exact rule
like this rule just it was so broad
nobody had it on paper nobody
could find what it really was saying so
i went ahead and emailed people this was
their first response was that we try to
keep everything religiously neutral we
talked about it like well if that's the
case then they're trying to keep
everything religiously neutral
then people who have crosses of tattoos
or biblical verses or whatever
shouldn't be able to show those and so i
that's what i wrote back probably two
weeks later i got another email back
and there
that's when they pulled up this rule and
it said safety reason now they went to
safety you know when you go to safety
you can't really question safety
anywhere like anybody can say oh that's
a safety precaution so no
[Music]
[Music]
wow it's tough you know she had to sit
out you take that year off it's not an
ideal scenario had she been able to go
over there right out of college there's
no doubt that she would have found a
home
and she would have been able to move up
you know
fairly rapidly i believe
[Music]
you know everybody thinks yeah it's just
a sport
but it's a place where once you step on
the court you have no other worries like
you could have
the worst things going on in your life
but when i play basketball
i worry about nothing
and i think
that's how you know you love the game
when you let nothing affect it
i'm used to
warming up on a court getting ready to
play a game
[Music]
not being able to be that person anymore
it's just like well what can i do to
replace that
right now i don't know who i am
it's just it's a scary feeling you know
because
i was so used to
being a basketball player and i don't
know how to handle it
[Music]
it's just like
am i anybody without basketball you know
and it's weird it's like
am i still myself
you don't know
i don't know how to be normal right now
[Music]
probably just doing like a mini clinic
if you want to call it just have them do
fun get some fun games probably
we'll see when they get out here
welcome song
are you guys ready yeah all right all
right so come on i'm just going to warm
you guys up a little bit first first
move is going to be a crossover
now the key is to dribble low you want
to keep the ball below your knees okay
like this cross
okay
what's the key
the ball has to be where
you are
nice nice
okay go ahead
good job
it's hard being a young muslim woman in
america you have to be strong
regardless like it takes strength to
walk outside and look different than
everybody else
people kind of look at you different
when they see muslim women they kind of
they have this you know stereotype that
they're quiet that they're submissive
that they're not supposed to do these
certain things and
i kind of felt like when i did wear it
when i first started wearing it i felt
like i couldn't be myself
i
had to find a way
come on somebody make it
[Music]
got her
you're out good job good job next person
next person
shoot it shoot it
[Music]
i feel proud of myself
[Music]
you know there was times where i felt
like you know maybe i should
not cover anymore just so i can play but
it's just like is it worth it
you know do you want to conform
right now in this world i think
conforming is one of the worst things
you can possibly do
i was going to finish school i was going
to play basketball i was going to do all
this stuff and now it's just like a huge
question mark
do i want to play for organization that
wasn't letting me play from the start
you know that kind of goes through my
head like these people don't want me to
play in general so why am i still
going at it so hard and and you know
eventually if it does work out play for
them
what am i going to end up doing
you did good you won you really won
good job y'all want to play again
play again
she's willing to fight this fight
for the young girls that she's
instructing now those that have this
love for basketball who will not
suddenly hit this roadblock and i think
that she understands
that they are going to go up against
this ban
in 10 years 20 years
if she doesn't do something about it
she has
had to question herself
and her faith
and her future every aspect of her life
her identity was as a basketball player
what it's done is that it made her
reassess everything
[Music]
was her love for the game
stronger than her faith
is she really being forced
to make a choice
between faith and sport
you know and talking to people yesterday
basically no one's ever heard of the
hijab man in fiba right um and so even
though these are people who are
extremely expert in sports even your
fellow athletes
um don't have never heard of it before
and they were they were kind of shocked
this has probably cost you your career
and you know
it's turned you into an advocate
so i'm not really nervous because i mean
i'm
just telling my story and i think
at this point just after hearing
the panels yesterday
i think it's important that they see
something that's kind of real life
people didn't know about fiba and hijab
and all of this type of stuff and they
were really like this one woman cried
and so just to see
other people like caucasian i don't know
what religion they may have been where
they're from the country like they're
affected by it regardless you know and
so you can see how universal this
situation is and that's why i've been
saying lately that it's bigger than
basketball
[Music]
the hard part is these federations are
are very difficult to penetrate it's
difficult to find and get access to
these people it's in a sort of elitist
you know secret society it does take
people um of power so people at usa
basketball if the nba or the wnba could
get involved fantastic that's the kind
of change we need we need people with
power
i was on the fifa executive committee
for three years as one of the first few
women in the room in all our searching
we were unable to find a single example
of a woman having a head scarf injury
playing football and it took a couple of
years but eventually we succeeded in
having the rule changed
well i haven't been told i couldn't play
because of what i wore but i was told
that i couldn't play on this field
because that's fields for the men
i've been told i had to play on you know
i played on substandard fields had
substandard uniforms
uh got a handshake for winning the
women's world cup in 1991. i know what
that feels like it's important that
people can see
that the game reflects
the world's population it's it's a world
game there's around i think around 500
million muslim women and girls in the
world to me it's a powerful symbolic
message that you belong
[Music]
i'm here because i need help you know i
need help and i need
support from government officials from
people at the top of federations this
was way past basketball and fifa like
this is what this whole meeting was
about is human rights
[Applause]
her testimony inspired the room she
doesn't want anyone else
to feel this type of loss and to have to
find a new way to navigate her life
to figure out what am i going to do if i
don't have basketball
the legacy of exclusion that women face
in sport
is something that will be overcome it's
it's not a matter of weather it's just a
it's just a matter of when and how soon
i would just
say one more thing as a message to
bilkies and many more builders are out
there sport is
a birthright
and
it should be yours you should be able to
play
[Music]
[Music]
don't be afraid the
future
is
[Music]
on your voice is be afraid
don't be afraid there's power in what
you say
in what you say on your voice don't be
afraid
don't be afraid
[Applause]
how could girlie ever be an insult all
the women i know are once more in
culture what would happen if we all
believe with a little less aggression
more femininity we have to value girls
more than their looks the biggest threat
is a girl with a book the system must
make room for all that we do we've been
bleeding each month till we gave birth
to you
[Music]
you